the fires have left their mark in Haifa
like many year balasana has returned
home to see how things are his house is
still standing but it's not habitable
your schnitzel many things are broken
water has got into the house in some
places the roof is gone the whole
structure is damaged the electrical
system has completely melted away
coolios the family only renovated the
house for years ago inside the extent of
the damage becomes apparent the
government has promised immediate aid
but it's not yet clear who will pay for
the damage awesome shall official a
cooler the Prime Minister and the
government have promised us a lot
anymore micro version I hope we will get
this aid is good and get it fast for all
the people who have damage like this
isla little solution is go here and then
you remain McWhorter the flames were
particularly intense now two days later
the devastation is becoming clear over
60,000 people had to be evacuated here
in Haifa also in this neighborhood
people had to leave their homes now
they're coming back to pick up the
pieces it's not just residents returning
curious onlookers have also come to
survey the damage hey much intimidation
when I saw all this I had to cry my
heart is heavy all this demolition
people here have lost so much push our
luck alone machine did they simply get
matches and started burning all our all
countries it's not in high fight in
Jerusalem devil why did they do that the
government believes many of the fires
were started deliberately and a spoken
of a new arsonist terrorism but some
believe it's just a blame game in a long
email I don't have to listen to
politicians who after just one hour
think they know that this is an arsonist
Intifada dog shark they should come up
with evidence if the politicians throw
oil on the fire and give people ideas
for next time in similar dishes Intifada
shallots a tort the police investigation
is ongoing and the clean-up operation
is likely to continue for some time to
come